sabemos que la multiplicación de números
escalares es conmutativa y eso quiere
decir por poner un ejemplo
sabemos que 5 por 11 es exactamente
igual que 11 por 5 esta es tal cual la
propiedad conmutativa y todos los
números escalares la cumplen podemos
poner otro ejemplo o sea también 3 x
menos 7 es exactamente igual a poner
primero por aquí el menos 7 y
multiplicar de este lado por el 3 y ese
es el chiste de la propiedad conmutativa
de la multiplicación que no importa en
qué orden estamos multiplicando los
números o sea por ejemplo si queremos
ser super generales podemos poner el
escalar
y multiplicarlo por el escalar b y eso
es exactamente igual a tomar el escalar
de primero y multiplicar de este lado
por el escalar y lo que quiero hacer en
este vídeo es ver si hay algo parecido
pero para las matrices o sea si la
multiplicación entre dos matrices es
conmutativa lo que quiero que nos
preguntemos en este vídeo es si tomamos
una matriz y aquí está la matriz a y la
multiplicamos por una matriz de la
matriz de si esta multiplicación de
estas dos matrices en este orden es
igual a tomar primero a la matriz b
esta es la matriz p y luego multiplicar
la por la matriz a ok lo que estamos
haciendo es cambiar el orden en el que
estamos multiplicando a estas dos
matrices y nos preguntamos si esos dos
productos son iguales si fueron iguales
eso sería lo equivalente a la propiedad
conmutativa
los escalares de la que estábamos
hablando ahora para poder decir que la
multiplicación entre matrices es
conmutativa necesitamos que esto pase
pero para todas las matrices as y todas
las matrices vez ok no puede ser nada
más para algunas cuentas entonces la
pregunta es si esto siempre es cierto y
te sugiero que le pongas pausa al vídeo
y trates de averiguar si esto siempre es
cierto o no bueno podemos empezar por
pensar en algunas cosas digamos que
tenemos por aquí un ejemplo de una
matriz
y que esta matriz es una matriz de
dimensiones 5 x 2 y queremos multiplicar
esta matriz a por una matriz b que es
una matriz de 2 x 3
entonces si estamos multiplicando dos
matrices y nos fijamos y vemos que el
número de columnas de la matriz a es
exactamente igual al número de filas
de la matriz be entonces sabemos que si
podemos multiplicar estas dos matrices y
que además la multiplicación de estas
dos matrices va a ser otra matriz a la
cual le vamos a llamar la matriz ce que
tiene el mismo número de filas que la
matriz a o sea que tiene cinco filas y
el mismo número de columnas que la
matriz b o sea que tiene tres columnas
bueno pero qué pasa cuando
multipliquemos ve por a ver vamos a ver
voy a copiar y pegar la matriz b y la
queremos multiplicar por la matriz
a que la queremos por aquí entonces qué
pasa cuando multiplicamos primero b y
después a pues tenemos aquí que esta
multiplicación no está definida porque
porque tenemos que el número de columnas
de b que es este 3 de aquí no es igual
al número de filas de la matriz a que es
este 5 de aquí entonces esta
multiplicación no está definida no
está
definida
y ya con esto ya tenemos un ejemplo de
cómo esta propiedad conmutativa no
siempre es cierta o sea a veces ni
siquiera está definido lo que significa
b por a entonces esto no siempre sucede
ok
el orden en el que multiplicamos a las
matrices si importa pero bueno podríamos
llegar a pensar que esta propiedad si se
cumple siempre que esta multiplicación
esté definida por ejemplo si estamos
tomando matrices cuadradas o si
definimos a las matrices de cierta forma
así es que vamos a ver un caso más
concreto donde esta multiplicación si
está definida pero donde esta propiedad
conmutativa no se da entonces tenemos
por aquí la matriz 1 2 - 3 menos 4
y la vamos a multiplicar por la matriz
menos 200 menos 3
y eso pues nos va a dar una matriz que
también va a ser una matriz de 2 x 2 de
esta matriz de 2 por 2 y a ver vamos a
sacar esta entrada de la primera columna
y primera fila así es que tenemos que
tomar la primera fila de esta matriz y
la primera columna de esta otra matriz y
tomamos menos dos por uno menos dos más
dos por cero y simplemente un -2 y ahora
para sacar esta entrada tenemos que
multiplicar la primera fila por la
segunda columna 1 por 0 0 + 2 por menos
3 menos 6 ahora vamos con esta entrada
que está en la primera columna y segunda
fila segunda fila y primera columna y
nos queda menos 3 por menos 2 más menos
4 por 0 6 y finalmente la última entrada
tomamos la segunda
y la segunda columna y nos queda menos 3
por 0 más menos 4 por menos 3 12 y ahora
vamos a ver qué pasa pero si los
multiplicamos con otro orden aunque
entonces por aquí primero a la matriz
morada
menos 200 menos 3 y multiplicamos de
este lado esta otra matriz
qué es la matriz 12 menos tres menos
cuatro y eso pues nos va a dar otra
matriz de dos por dos entonces a ver
primera entrada tenemos que multiplicar
esta fila por esta columna nos queda 1
pero menos 2 - 2 + 0 por menos tres
menos dos y mira hasta ahorita con lo
que llevamos si nos están quedando
parecidas claro que llevamos una entrada
de cuatro no deberíamos emocionarnos
tanto ahora vamos con esta entrada que
es la primera fila y la segunda columna
menos dos por dos menos cuatro más cero
por menos cuatro entonces nos queda
simplemente un -4 y mira ya nos quedaron
distintas estas dos matrices porque aquí
tenemos un -4 y aquí tenemos un -6
entonces este es un ejemplo de dos
matrices que si las multiplicamos con
cierto orden nos queda una matriz pero
que si cambiamos el orden en el que las
estamos multiplicando
a otra matriz así es que no siempre
sucede eso de que la multiplicación de
las matrices sea conmutativa ok no
sucede el orden de la multiplicación de
dos matrices es muy importante pero
bueno hay que terminar de hacer esta
multiplicación solo para no dejarla
inconclusa
entonces esta entrada es la primera
columna y segunda fila 1 por 0 0 menos
tres por menos 3 es un 9 mira también
son distintas en esta entrada y
finalmente última fila por última
columna 2 por 0 0 menos tres por menos 4
12 así es que aquí tenemos un ejemplo
donde la multiplicación de dos matrices
está definida sin importar el orden en
el que los estemos multiplicando o sea
si ponemos primero la verdad y luego la
morada o primero la morada y luego laver
de la multiplicación si está definida
pero no son iguales y entonces este es
un ejemplo que muestra que la
multiplicación entre matrices no es
conmutativa